[Music]
please settle in I see people are still
coming
I see empty spaces make yourselves
comfortable
while you settle in can you tell me has
anyone built a neural network in this in
this room raise your hand
okay quite a few and among the others if
I say things like that's a convolutional
layer or cross-entropy loss if it rings
a bell if you know what I'm what I'm
talking about raise your hand okay a few
as well all the others you will not be
able to follow no I'm joking
no this talk is specifically designed to
take all of you developers through the
learning curve and today we will build a
neural network together from scratch to
the to something that I believe is I
mean a good quality neural network and
if some of you have have seen other
talks from the tensorflow without a PhD
series today we will be focusing on the
latest advances in visual processing
neural networks and what are the
architecture ideas that go into a good
neural network today so let's start and
for that we need a data set so what can
we do let's head to Cagle the data
science community I went there and I
found this data set of little twenty by
twenty tiles with airplanes and non
airplanes
I actually trained plane spotting us
with quite a nice activity why don't we
build something that can recognize
airplanes from not airplanes and then
continue building an an airplane
detection neural network so how do we
start well let's take the neural network
manual 101 on the first page and on the
first page it says this is fully
connected or dense neural network so the
image comes in as a set of pixels and we
flatten all the pixels into one big
vector and we will be processing that
big vector the white circle
you see our neurons so neuron in a
neural network will always do the same
thing
a neuron does a weighted sum of all of
its inputs and then feed this sum
through what is called an activation
function that's just a function number
in number out but in neural networks
this activation function is always non
linear this is what this is the key
thanks to which neural networks can
solve non linear problems so you can
layer those layers of neurons the the
second layer instead of doing weighted
sums of pixels does weighted sums of the
outputs of the previous layer you could
have as many layers as you want and then
at the very end I added a layer with
just two neurons and here since I'm
building a classifier something that
will classify those images into airplane
non airplane my hope is that with the
correct weights these two neurons one of
them will will have a very strong output
when this is a plane and the other one
will have a very strong output if this
is not a plane
so we will need to choose the activation
functions correctly and again looking at
the neural network 101 manual most of
the time the activation function you use
is called a Rayleigh and the manual says
if you're building a classifier there is
one exception on the very last layer you
will use a different activation function
which is called softmax so I will dive
into those two on the next slide but
first let's write the code for this so
this is what it looks like in tensor
flow the first line just flattens all
the pixels as one big vector of pixels
and then in tensor flow you have this
high level API which can instantiate an
entire layer in in one line so here I
have instantiated by three layers the
first one with 200 neurons then 20 and
the last one with two neurons as you see
the intermediate layers are activated
with this Rayleigh activation function
and at the end
need to do something different so if you
are building a classifier let's follow
the recipe the recipe says if you're
building a classifier the last layer
must have the softmax activation
function and you will apply you will
compute now some distance between what
your network is predicting and the
correct answer we are doing here
supervised training so we don't know
initially what those weights are we are
doing weighted sums but we don't know
what those weights are and we will be
feeding examples into this model where
we know the answers in comparing what
the model is predicting against our
answers so we need a distance function
and in a typical classifier the distance
you will use is called cross-entropy i
don't even necessarily need to know at
this point what that is tensorflow
actually has a function combined
function that applies this loss softmax
activation and computes the
cross-entropy distance between what the
network predicts and the correct answer
this is called a loss or error function
and that's what we want to minimize so
as soon as you have built your layers
and computed your loss an error function
tensorflow can take over you pick any of
the optimizers that are available here I
chose Adam optimizer
and you can't be asked it to minimize
this loss this will give you a training
operation which tensorflow with and will
then repeat in a loop and what happens
in this training operation is all the
training magic tensorflow will look at
your loss will differentiate it
relatively to all the losses sorry to
all the weight in the system obtain
something that is called a gradient
mathematically and apply an algorithm
gradient descent that figures out how to
change the weights in your network so as
to minimize this loss so as to make this
loss smaller
and so you will be feeding in images and
correct answers in batches and at each
batch tensorflow
slightly adjusts the weights in your
network so as to make the loss the
distance would be between what your
network is predicting and the correct
answer smaller and smaller and smaller
that is how you train a neural network
so just a little look at those two
activation functions so here's again
just one neuron ok weighted sums of all
of its inputs usually you add something
called the bias that's an another degree
of freedom something that will be
determined by training and you feed this
through an activation function so this
rayleigh function that we have used on
the intermediate layers this is what it
looks like it's a very very simple
function 0 for all negative values
identity for all positive values the
softmax activation function that you use
on the last layer here I have
represented a last layer with 10 neurons
so that's if you are doing a
classification into 10 categories so
that softmax function is slightly more
complex well actually it's just an
exponential so you compute your weighted
sum and elevate it to the exponential
and then you normalize across those 10
neurons well the output I I put in a
little animation here is what it does
boom it pulls the winner apart ok but
without destroying it's not max it
doesn't completely nullify all the bad
answers so you still have signal if your
network is miss recognizing something ok
that's why it's called soft max it's
it's max but in a soft way it pulls the
winner apart but it doesn't discard all
the bad all the negative information
which is still useful for training
alright so we have all that we have
built our network now we can train it we
have our data set during training well
so here is what goes in in the window
which is brew so really one soft max the
two activation functions the
cross-entropy was the distance function
we used ok
and it's ready okay let's test actually
before we go there a word about the the
the tooling were using here so this is
the code is in tensor flow the tool I'm
using to actually run the training is ml
Engine on Google's cloud it has one
super useful feature that I love is that
whatever infrastructure I run my
training on when the job is done it
shuts it down okay that's not rocket
science but I just can't be bothered
shutting down my machines because and
figuring out if my jobs I've done ml
engine gives me the job based view I can
show you here that I need to work my
jobs running finished and when they are
finished the the the machine or the
cluster goes down and finally tensor
board that's a visualization tool that
you have in tensor flow where you see
all your curves and and you can see
what's going on okay so I will oh no I
can't skip this we're handling images so
I will have to introduce another piece
of technology here those dents neural
networks that you have seen they work
well for a lot of things but for images
you need something else and those are
called convolutional neural networks so
bear with me here in a convolutional
neural network the what is called a
neuron behaves a little bit different a
neuron this little cube here that's the
output sees only a little fraction of
the image right above him okay it
doesn't do weighted sums of all the
pixel of the image just a little portion
and then the next neuron actually does a
weighted sum of again a little portion
just and above him but using the same
weights so it's actually a filtering
operation you pick a set of weights as
many weights as I have highlighted cubes
in the image over there my image has red
green and blue channels because it is a
color image okay so you have red green
and blue
and I'm doing weighted sums of all these
pixels but using the same weights at
each position
it's a filtering operation and once I
have moved this filter across my entire
image with correct padding on the sides
I have as many outputs as I had pixels
initially so how many weights did I use
well as many as highlight as the
highlighted pixels so that's 4 by 4 by 3
which is 4 1 4 16 48 48 weights typical
neural networks have something in the
tens or hundreds of thousands of weight
so we need a way of giving this more
freedom more weights to play with in a
good way is to pick another set of
weights and repeat the operation so you
pick just another set of weights repeat
the operation and you obtain a new
channel of data in the output and you
can do that again and again which means
that a convolutional layer in a neural
network will transform data cube into
another data cube and this is the shape
of this convolutional the matrix of
weights so the first two digits the
first two number is 4 by 4 that's the
size of the filter in pixels the third
digit is how many channels of
information here you were reading in the
input image so 3 channels red green blue
that's this number here and then you
repeat this operation 4 times with four
different sets of weights and as a
result you obtain four different
channels of outputs and the four is this
last number here so this is a
convolutional layer and since it has a
number of input channels and a number of
output channels you can chain them and a
convolutional network will be a sequence
of those layers transforming the data
data cube into another data cube then
filtering that a direct you began
transforming it into a new data cube and
so on so this data cube can grow in both
directions
vertical direction or the horizontal
direction so we have seen here in the
vertical direction that's just a number
of times you repeat the filtering
operation with a different set of of of
weights but how do you adjust the size
in the in the horizontal direction
usually the idea is to go from an image
and boil the information down into
something smaller like recognizing what
is in the image so two two choices for
that actually we have many options the
first one is to play with the step of
the convolution instead of doing those
weighted sums pixel by pixel you jump
every second pixel and well mechanically
you obtain twice fewer results in the
output
that's the stride parameter that you see
here stride 2 or stride 1 and there is a
second option which is actually more
used and that's called maxed pooling and
here the idea is interesting
these are filtering operations so as the
network trains you will those filters
will train to pattern match or recognize
certain features in the image let's say
there is one that trains to recognize
little horizontal lines another one that
specializes in vertical lines and so on
so the output of the filter is basically
something like here I have seen a little
horizontal line here I have seen nothing
here I have seen nothing and so on the
max pooling operation takes four of
those in a in a square and just keep the
max which makes sense because you are
interested in the value of the filter
that was maximum at that point because
that is where the filters I have
actually seen something the other ones
which you can which you discard or I've
seen nothing and that's not really
interesting so this is a basic
subsampling operation you take your
image you take it was not your image but
your data cube you take the the data
points four by four and squares two by
two and just
keep the maximum and again that reduces
the size of the data cube horizontally
and the little guy he points something
out that there is something called a
one-by-one convolution well if you're a
mathematician that doesn't make much
sense like one by one filter that's just
multiplying by a constant right that's
not very useful but again we are doing
this filtering multiple times with a
different constants so one by one
convolution actually makes sense
it's the weighted sum of this little
column of data points and that way yet
some might be interesting so we will see
later that one by one convolutions
actually in convolutional networks make
sense all right so this is what we will
build there are three convolutional
layers we have our image here three
convolutional layers and then at the end
we need to connect this to our softmax
layer which will do the airplane
non-arable and classification so the
last data cube we reshape it we flatten
it out as one big vector here and this
we apply normal dense layers to this
vector and end up with our softmax
softmax activation and softmax
cross-entropy loss because this is a
classifier after that a lot of
experimentation and a lot of
regularization so I will not go into
this you have many other talks in the
tensor flow with our PhD series that
focus on what is regularization for now
all you need to know these are
techniques standard techniques that can
improve the convergence and I am quite
good at those techniques so plus another
one which is hyper parameter tuning as
you have seen there are many parameters
here the number the size of the filters
the number of layers the strides in so
on and so forth
you can well if you if you if you know
what you're doing you know
the acceptable ranges for those
parameters but still it's a lot of work
to explore this parameter space so
that's why am L engine gives you this
hyper parameter tuning module where you
just define your space and you and say
go ahead try all the combinations so
there are a couple of ways of trying out
all the combinations the basic one is
just grid search and you know that's
where you would start just you know map
out all the possible combinations of
parameters and search throughout the
whole grid it's actually slightly faster
to do a random search than a grid search
that's a bit counterintuitive we are
rational people
I like the grid but it turns out random
is slightly better but ml engine does
thread algorithm that is called Bayesian
optimization and I won't go into this
one it's it's something where from one
set of runs it can mathematically
determine which part of the parameter
space has been mapped and where is still
missing information and focus on that
other part of the parameter space in an
optimal way so that's what that is the
best way of doing hyper parameter name
and m/l engine does that how well this
is how you package your files to go to
ml engine just you your your Python code
in an inner folder and a config file
which usually has just this in it scaled
here basic GPU which means one machine
with the GPU and then you go you go run
the run is here you use the g-cloud
command line g-cloud ml engine jobs
submit training and you train if you add
these lines here to the config file you
start instead of starting a normal
training job you start a hyper parameter
tuning job so what do you what did I do
here I said I want to maximize some
metric there is a way of specifying what
your metrics are in your tensor flow
code so here my accuracy I want fixes 50
trials 10 trials in parallel
again be inching a Bayesian optimization
so it it derives useful information from
trials for the next ones so it's it's
better not to run all the trials at the
same time even if you have the necessary
hardware and then you say which
parameters you want so I have one
parameter called LR - which is an
integer min/max values the scale this
other one is a categorical parameter and
it will try all those parameters in some
optimal way so using all this the
network you have seen here this one plus
my best knowledge of regularization
techniques plus hyper parameter tuning I
was able to bring this network to an
accuracy of 99 per 6 percent and I was
very very proud of myself until I tried
this network in real life let me show
you a demo well first of all just a
little trick how do you transform a
classifier into a detector it's actually
fairly easy if you have a big image just
cut it out in 20 by 20 tiles slightly
overlapping and maybe at different
resolutions which you resize then to
20/20 run the classifier wherever you
see a plane you put a box there and you
have a detector so here we have that San
Francisco and this was my very first
model this one not yet very good just
the data I had not not much
regularization not much high / / I'm
tuning I guess it's it looks like it's
doing something it's not completely
horrible so it's encouraging then I used
my best skills to hyper parameter tune
and regularize the hell out of this and
I obtained my ninety nine point six
percent accuracy model which I will now
run for you and and wait for it it's
absolutely horrible you see here let me
show you lots and lots of
false-positive everywhere it's it's it's
noisy it's not clean so here is the
first lesson of neural networks there is
your training data there is your
evaluation data on which you compute
your accuracy of course computing your
accuracy on your training data would be
cheating and then there is a real life
in real life has nothing to do with
either your training or your evaluation
data real life is hard so with a lot of
effort actually augmenting the data set
adding tiles of non planes hoping that
this would make things better I was able
to increase the accuracy of this model a
little bit but yeah as you will see it's
it's still not great and that was the
end of my neural network 101 handbook so
from now on you've got to read papers
all right
that's scary so before we go there let
me give you a couple of just tensorflow
tips to use ml engine really to the best
of its capabilities I advise you to wrap
your model into what is called an
estimator API that's just because in in
estimator we have written for you a ton
of boilerplate code that is not
interesting to write things like
checkpoints regularly outputting
checkpoints so that if you're training
crashes after 24 hours you can restart
from where you were you were you where
exporting the model at the end so that
you have something that is ready to
deploy to a serving infrastructure or or
distributed training the distribution of
algorithms of distributed training also
baked in into estimator and to wrap your
model in an estimator you need those
oops sorry those four things here and
and then you can run train and evaluate
which will alternate
training and evaluation phases so that
in your output you get nice curves with
your training data training metrics
evaluation metrics you can compare the
two and so on
mostly what I what you need to provide
are those four functions here so let's
go through quickly through them it's
it's it's really nothing fancy the model
function its your layers
okay that's your model and then it
returns whatever a model is supposed to
return the predictions the loss you you
you put the loss into into an optimizer
and you've got this training operation
which the estimator will run in in a
loop and whatever evaluation metrics you
care about
so that's your model then the training
input function and I'm putting code on
the slides here okay you don't try to
read all the code I will give you the
the highlights of what is there in the
code you will not be you not have the
time to see all the syntax so the
training input function that's the
function that will define how your data
goes into the model and I use the this
data set API and that's really good
because this data set API is designed
for out of memory data sets you define
what it what your data set is and then
as you as your model is training the
data is loaded and the loading triggers
the loading of additional files from
disk if the data set is does not fit in
in memory and by the way no data set
ever fits in memory I mean no real data
set so here for it for example I'm
reading images and well focus on this
here the data set is initialized from
files get matching files in a directory
all the files in a directory and then I
like this syntax it's really the
workflow I'm used to I apply some
loading operations which will load those
files and and decompress them and so on
I usually need to shuffle my data to
batch it into batches because the you
know the training always proceeds by
batches and usually I repeat it and
definitely and my data set is done
and finally the serving input function
so estimator also saves periodically a
snapshot of your model which is ready to
be deployed again on ml Engine ml Engine
has those two parts one is for training
the second one allows you with one click
to put your model behind the rest API
but for that when your model will will
be listening behind this REST API it
will be receiving data in a certain
format and usually you wants to do stuff
with that before feeding it into your
model so if you don't this is the
do-nothing pass-through starving input
function but if you do this is the
serving input function which I used to
first decompress the incoming images
from JPEG to pixels and then I also
implemented right in this the the
scanning operation you remember to
transform a classifier to detector you
need to cut your image into little 20 by
20 tiles overlapping at different
resolutions actually I was able to do
this on the fly in the deployed model
this is the code so it's about 10 lines
don't read it but I find it interesting
that I was able to do this on the fly in
the deployed model and the demo I was
showing here this is a JavaScript UI
which is calling into ml engine sending
a part of the image to ml engine and
then getting the results back so this is
actually live alright so we need to read
papers there are many papers for
detection and image image work in
detection there are many papers I want
to talk about these two and a little bit
about the others but mostly focus on the
big ideas and the first bigger yes and I
need a new data set unfortunately
because now I will be doing a real
detection those 20 by 20 tiles of planes
are in airplanes that's no good any
longer now I have to handle I want to
handle big images indirectly output a
square box around each airplane
so I had to build my own data set in
this case it was actually possible
I beat I built myself a little
JavaScript UI and then I went clicking
on airplanes and and well I you know it
was about a day day of work so not so
bad here all right so let's start with
this an inception this is the paper that
really brought to the table some of the
big ideas in this space on this side you
see what the inception model looks like
so all those little squares are covering
convolutional layers and what you see is
that it's weird I told you before that
convolutional layers should be sequenced
just piled up one layer next layer next
layer next layer and here we see
branches and then things coming back
what is that
so the big idea here is that you are
somewhere in your convolutional neural
network and then you ask yourself the
question what is the what is the best
here should I now add a 1x1
convolutional layer or maybe a 1x1
followed by a three a three by three or
maybe something else what is best and
they had the idea that you can actually
do all of these things in parallel and
simply concatenate in the very vertical
direction the results and they call this
a module basically during training the
network will decide which is the best
path to use for a specific image and a
specific task so this is this module
based approach that was one of the big
ideas the second by big area is called
filter factorization so what you see
here are is a sequence of two 3x3
filters you see let's look at this this
bottom one so this piece of data is
produced by some weighted sum of this
3x3 square here and if you look where
those data points in this 3x3 square are
coming from they actually come from some
combinations of this white data data
points in this five
by five a piece of the previous data so
it looks like two consecutive 3x3
filters do some combinations of a 5x5
zone in the same way as a 5x5 filter
will be doing combinations of data
points in a 5-11 5x5 zone it's not the
same combinations but let's count the
weights 5x5 filter has five by five by
one by one that's the depth I mean the
number of channels that's 25 weights now
if we count the weights 4 3 2
consecutive 3 by 3 filters it's 3 by 3
plus 3 by 3 which is 18
hey 2 3 by 3 filters are 30% cheaper in
terms of number of weights than one big
5x5 filter they're not doing the same
thing but it's worth checking if for our
purpose it's it would it wouldn't be
enough that's the second big idea and
the third video a big idea are those one
by one convolutions which again could
sound funny to a mathematician but once
you realize that you are applying many
of them and that this one by one
convolution is actually a weighted sum
of all of the pieces of data in this
little column it's it's like saying well
I have many different filtering results
like I have filtered my image for
horizontal lines and then vertical lines
and so on and maybe the feature I'm
looking for is some combination of those
filters sometimes I'm looking for only
the horizontal line a little bit of the
vertical ones the one by one convolution
can give me the right combination for
that purpose of course the weights
defining the combination will be trained
and one more this one is a bit of
cheating so at the very end you do your
convolutional layers and at the very end
you want you classify if you're building
a classifier so let's say classify in
five classes typically you would take
the law
datacube here reshape it into a vector
apply a dense layer and then and then
softmax activation and you've got your
five classes but if all you're trying to
do is obtain five numbers there is an
easier way those dense layers they
connect everything with everything they
tend to be heavy in terms of weights
there is an easier way you need five
numbers okay let's take this this cube
of data just slice it up horizontally
like a piece of bread in five slices
average those five slices and you've got
five numbers you can apply softmax
activation on it if you want and you've
got the same thing with zero weights so
it's a lot cheaper but warning it only
works if you care about global
information and only global information
if you want to classify an image as dog
versus cat versus sunset yeah this will
work if you actually care about the
localization of stuff in your image like
we do you are averaging your filtering
output across the entire image so you
will lose the the that information so
not good for our purpose here but still
an interesting idea to put this all
together into a simple architecture the
inception architecture is a bit
complicated for my taste but this
squeeze net paper actually put all of
this in a you know in a very elegant
architecture they said let's build
everyone out of these kinds of modules
so we start with the one by one
convolution where we usually reduce the
horizontal size of our data cube and
then we have a parallel module which is
one by one convolution and a three by
three convolution in parallel we stack
the results and the stacking usually
increases the the number of channels in
the data cube again so they call it a
squeeze and expand layer and when you
put those two together they call them
fire modules and your full model becomes
a nice succession of fire modules max
pooling operations which
decrease the size of your data cube
horizontally then again a sequence of
fire modules then you decrease the size
again horizontally and so on it's simple
and I find it elegant so let's build it
but I wanted to test this squeeze net
idea against a more traditional you know
layer layer layer layer layer
architecture and we'll go into the
yellow paper you look only once
that's the detection paper which we will
use to actually produce our squares
around airplanes in that paper they had
this this this very simple architecture
that they called darknet and I thought
well maybe we can compare the two so you
see on the squeeze net size we have this
alpha this these squeeze modules here
sorry no here one by one followed by in
parallel three by three and a one by one
convolution and then the max pulling
operation and then it continues so you
see the data cube is a small one
squeezed then it's expanded that is
squeezed and it's expanded and so on on
the other side is just a sequence and
actually the the depth of the cube is
roughly constant until the end and we
just have these max pooling operations
which restrict the size of the image
horizontally so we'll see which one
fairs better now how do we actually
detect airplanes this is what the yellow
algorithm does and it's you look only
once it's a one shot detector it's not
you live only once it divides the image
into a grid and it will say well each
grid cell will now produce a certain
number of boxes so each grid cell will
designed to output four values which is
XY the center of the the box the the
yellow box here and the center can be
anywhere in the grid cell so x and y are
between minus 1 and 1 relatively to the
center of the grid cell and it will also
it will also compute
size of this box the size can be
anything okay this the the box can grow
to the to be as big as the image itself
it's not constrained in the grid cell
and also some confidence factor which
tells us whether we if there is a plane
here or not okay
and you can adjust how many of those
boxes each grid cell is able to generate
1 2 3 we will see what's best this is
the loss they have in their paper okay
so let me please allow me to simplify it
a little bit the first line actually is
it's kind of okay
it's it's the error on the position of
the box so you compare the Box you have
against your ground truth and you see
this a squared square of differences of
the center so that's the error on the
position I like that the second one is
the error on the size of the box
well they had let rectangles I have only
squares so let's kill the hate only with
and for some reason they thought it was
oh no they in the paper they argue why
they put in the square root of the size
and not the size itself I didn't
understand that so I remove this the the
next thing is the error so this is on
detected airplanes what is the country
so do the error on the confidence factor
where you had an airplane here I just
replaced the ideal value by one when you
have an airplane that ideal confidence
is one the next one is the same thing
for four four boxes where you do not
have an airplane so they are the the
ideal is zero and the last line they
were detecting many categories they were
actually detecting cars and dogs and and
blah blah blah
I have only airplanes the last line for
them was the missed detection error
detecting a car as a dog
I have only only airplanes or not
airplanes I don't care about this
they also so this is a multi a composite
loss so they had this idea that maybe
the the different parts of this loss
should be weighted different
again I didn't understand why so remove
them and and that's about it so the only
thing that is still left and there is a
hard problem is this you know operator
they called one which is actually the
assignments between the boxes your
generate in the ground truth and that's
not an easy problem so of course for a
grid cell you know that if you generate
if you have a ground truth box that is
centered centered in one of those grid
cells you will want to pair it with some
box generated by that grid cell but
those grid cells are allowed to generate
more than one box and you're allowed to
have more than one an airplane you know
in a grid cell so you might have more
than one ground through the box how do
you do the pairings yeah well there's a
lot of choice and when I looked in the
paper they said oh well we did something
simple and actually our algorithm is not
very good for swarm type things when you
have you know a flock of birds or an
airport for a full of airplanes it's not
very good for that thank you guys so
well we'll see you will try to play with
those parameters how do we build this so
very simply you've got the end of your
convolutional Network you've got a data
cube split it horizontally in your
end-by-end grid and then split it
vertically in four or maybe eight or
twelve depending on how many boxes you
want to generate per grid cell and then
the red boxes will become X the yellow
box is why the green box is the the size
of the box and and the blue ones will
will become the confidence factor you
just average all the values in them and
for all of those that you need to put
between minus one and one you feed them
through a hyperbolic tangent that puts
them between minus 1 and 1 and all those
that you need to put between 0 and 1 you
feed them through a sigmoid and that
puts them between 0 and 1 and you have
generated from an image 1 2 3 4 boxes
per grid cell which detect airplanes
that's it we're done the only thing now
is the work of the data scientists now
start a slow but steady process of
grinding through all the hyper
parameters of this model and trying to
improve the accuracy initially this is
what my first training run looked like
actually let me show you my my my real
numbers because I have them here so this
is initially what I had I wasn't sure it
was actually doing something at all you
know but why not initially I tried a
four by four grid and generating just
one box per grid cell so not very good I
realized that shuffling data is actually
super important big progress in so iou
that's the intersection of a union it's
a measure of how accurate those boxes
are relatively to the ground truth so I
tried with more boxes per cell like 4x4
but generating four boxes per grid cell
that doesn't work so well again it's a
hard problem to assign them to their
ground truth control counterparts you've
got four boxes per cell for ground truth
which one is which it's hard so this was
not very good so then I went to 8x8 and
then generating only one box per cell
yeah that's better because there is no
assignment problem there it's just one
box per cell I bumped it up to sixteen
by sixteen by two the grid
the yellow braid that is even better and
this time I tried to think very hard
about this assignment problem and and
devised an algorithm that would kind of
rationally do the pairings I think I
went by the distance from the center so
the first box is more susceptible to go
with with airplanes which are closer to
the center of the grid cell and the
second one more on the periphery then it
turned out that detailed mentation
varying at random the hue and the
orientation of the image
that actually helps a lot and finally
that lost waiting idea the multi part
part lost figuring out that some parts
should wait more it was actually a good
idea and that gave me a little a little
bit more accuracy yes as well and on
here you can see in the reverse order
the loss so the error function going
down as we do this and and finally the
the best one was with more layers so
these were with twelve hours the last
one is with seventeen layers and then we
got something so you want to see this
you know demo right let's go first model
so this is what we had the best model
obtained from the classifier now let's
try our first sixteen sixteen time by by
two so that the yellow grid you catch
images in sixteen by sixteen grid and
you generate two boxes per grid cell
let's go analyze it's much cleaner but
it's missing a lot of planes here this
is this is something you can solve with
with the data augmentation actually I
did not have any data augmentation here
but if by varying the the orientation of
my cells and the hue of the cells
randomly you got a big boost in
inaccuracy now we're talking now it
looks like a detector we still have some
false positives there is one here I I
saw a couple of other ones but it is not
so bad actually and if we jump to a
bigger model I think that from twelve to
seventeen layers I think we are pretty
good let's see if we are perfect we'll
see almost perfect well it missed this
this blue airplane here but that's
because I need more data with blue
airplanes but it's not so bad and I was
able to piece this together with Lego
bricks which appear in literature
without being a super specialist in in
machine learning and my message to you
here is that okay it's kind of hard but
it's not like fluid dynamics hard if you
are a good developer if you are a good
developer this is a learning curve
through which you can go I went through
this learning curve and and look my my
my airplane detection model now works it
will always have an accuracy of 99 point
something percent you can never go to
100 that's something you have to build
into your your use case your products
but you all of you here are capable of
building machine learning months alright
then just to finish I want to show you
the the tooling I was using so I'm using
ml engine ml engine has basically two
two great features one is my jobs I see
all my jobs running and the other one is
my models so with one click I can deploy
a model to production and it's served
behind a REST API with with with auto
scaling and I don't have to manage
anything I really love that I love my
job
tuning those models I don't not like the
job of chasing VMs and which one is
still running and why blah blah blah
ml engine once you wrap your model in
this estimator API it gives you a
one-line config access to many different
hardware architectures including TP use
actually but let's start with something
else so this is what I had initially
training on just one GPU and this is the
config file that you use for that skill
here a basic GPU that's one machine with
a GPU this model the 17 layer model the
bigger one
trains in 23 hours for a cost of 28
dollars
we have faster GPUs you can bring this
down to 10 hours I like that for the
same price but with a very just a config
change no change in your code you can
actually deploy this to a full cluster
of five machines with five gpu-z
and it's a cluster so you can go to 100
if your model scales with this one I'm
down to four and a half hours
that's that means much more productive
and with the better GPUs that actually
below two hours I wish I had that in the
very beginning but then I thought well
let's try those TPU things first of all
a little warning those TP used its new
yorky texture there is a little bit of a
porting effort to adapt your model to
GPUs we are working on that but right
now expect to spend some time tweaking
the code it will still work on GPUs once
you tweaked it but there are some things
that need to be done for this new
architecture it's a completely new chip
oh sorry
before that new intense reflow are those
distribution strategies so very soon as
soon as they shape it's in beta now you
will be able to reserve one box with
multiple GPUs in it and that's a
different trade off so you don't have
the network communication between the
GPUs but on the other hand you can put
100 of them in one box so it's a
different trade off and again it will be
available with just a config change so
now I want to TP use I this is available
I just ported it so I don't want yet to
show the numbers because it's not really
like a really you know benchmark with a
proper benchmarking benchmarking you
know set up but those numbers are not
secret cloud TPS are all available on a
mail engine today and I published the
code for this yesterday so all you have
to do is run it and you will see the
numbers and of course if they are if I
am putting them here it's because the
they are both both faster and cheaper
than the second best option you have
here on on this slide and very soon you
will be able to access not just one of
those TPU boards but sixty-four boards
so a full rack of them connected with a
high-speed interconnect and use all of
that as one big supercomputer
straight from ml engine with just a
configure with
just a conflict change if you want to
know more about this there is a session
exactly on TP use right after this
session but you'll have to cross the
street it's a very good session alright
so that's it thank you for for your
attention we have seen these the cloud
ml Engine and cloud TPU as products my
takeaway is not on the products but what
I want you to remember is that if you
are a good developer you can build a
machine learning model there are best
practices there are Lego blocks that
exists you have to follow what is a
state of the art but then you can piece
those pieces together and if you want if
you don't want you to build your own
models where we have a set of pre train
models and new we also have this cloud
auto ml product that actually this
morning it was announced that it was not
doing just vision but also more things
so I need to update my slide and with
that you can just throw your data at it
and let the system figure out the
architecture of your model that's quite
advanced I'm amazed that that we can
build this and I find this really really
really really marvelous and finally if
you want to learn more about how to
build models you can check out the other
chapters of the tensor flow without a
PhD series and all the code and code
labs and all that is available on github
you've got the URL over there thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]